seven days files with no money and
whatever country end up in Vancouver
pray come home with no friggin money
Barcelona New York trouble safe guys see
you later bye dummy
[Music]
- to be honest mayor I've never come to
an airport without a ticket or any idea
where we're friggin going meant yeah
it's a bit strange
so go into a foreign place no idea yet
where I'm going and the idea is that I
will buy a house with no money in seven
days in a foreign country
hey wassup so just arrived at London
Heathrow so these are the areas that
we're thinking we've got Vancouver
freaking Kong I don't know where some of
these places are Cape Town
Barcelona New York well Joyce says New
York as well okay New York yeah I mean
I'm comin I'll go freaking anywhere I
really don't care a lot of people say in
America I'd like to do America you know
why because what I did the financial
freedom challenge there was a lot of
people that said it doesn't work where
I'm from and it was a lot of people from
America that said that Turkey
come see me the straily I don't know if
Australia is on the list it could do to
buy Sydney a lot of people say Sydney
Sydney
you gotta see what happens you just go
up and out and see what see look look
see it but see what flights were
available we're just gonna see what's
available with pink in Australia or
America
[Music]
when where does the next plane go to go
to the next plane yeah
JFK after busy Ghanim as well so America
I'm coming for you baby
[Music]
in New York City New York New York
[Music]
roll friends I'm just filming don't
worry are you filming
yeah 7:00 a.m. so I'm gonna jump in the
shower are you filming
yes hey Samuel lives here and I'm
attempting to do the financial freedom
challenge in the United States of
America literally yesterday just drove
to the airport in London England jumped
on the next plane going and Here I am
now in New York City so I've got 7 days
starting from right now starting from 9
a.m. which is going to be 9 am very very
soon to buy a house in the United States
of America
using none of my own money so I don't
know exactly how I'm gonna do that I've
literally been walking around the
streets of New York City for the last
hour and a half but like a prowling lion
ready for 9 a.m. to start when 9 a.m.
starts that's where my challenge begins
and that's where I start trying to find
a house to buy with no money I've done
it in the United Kingdom now it's time
to try it in the United States of
America so New York I'm coming for you
man I'm coming for you so how am I gonna
do this what's my strategy I actually
have no idea but the foot here's my four
things that I want to do today and I can
control this number one I'm gonna meet
with property agents in the area I'm
gonna ring up property estate agents and
I'm just gonna say can I take you for a
coffee can we have a chat about the
market in the area number two I'm gonna
find out what the heck the economy's
doing around here what kind of strategy
will work our lease option agreements
legal or rent two rents legal is deal
packaging legal so I'll work out what
the markets like in New York and what
strategies I'm likely to be able to do
number three I want to meet with
property investors so I'm gonna have to
book onto some property networking
events I'm sure there's loads around
here it's only working frantically to
get on as fast as I can
some property event so I can meet with
like more than investors and pick their
brains number for it I'm just gonna
as many viewings as I possibly can so
I'm waiting like crazy I cannot wait for
it at 9:00 a.m. when it hits 9:00 a.m.
I'm going to be on finding out all the
web sites like the equivalent to gum
tree but in this country maybe
Craigslist I don't know and just
speaking to you motivated sellers
speaking to people that have got the
house they want to sell it and see how I
can help them so if I'm just gonna focus
on those four things by the end of the
day I should have meetings with estate
agents meetings with investors meetings
with motivated sellers and hopefully
some idea on what the heck New York City
is like as a property market and how I'm
gonna make money here so that's my plan
today cannot wait if I have not bought a
house in seven days and I have no money
to do this
say if I've not managed to find a free
house I failed times ticking and do this
where would you recommend the best
places are for investment in property in
New York investment and probably the
best place for Brooklyn Brooklyn why
Brooklyn brownstone has grown for 1.2
million oh jeez that's expensive 1920s
they were gone for fifteen twenty
thousand Wow
so they absolutely rocketed do you not
think it'd be better to find somewhere
where its houses a low where they will
rock it and then buy there doesn't exist
in New York anymore really really so how
would you how would one make money in
property in New York today I think I'm
starting out with little money Staten
Island New York City is extremely
expensive and there are cheaper areas
but the cheaper areas don't necessarily
mean you can make money there because
houses are cheap to buy but properties
also cheap to rent you have Queens Bronx
Brooklyn yeah and you have Manhattan
yeah in Staten Island Staten Island
Staten Island cheaper than anywhere else
in the city because this is really cheap
yeah okay I need to find some property
real estate solicitors and talk to them
about legalities of things like rent to
rent lease option agreements deal
packaging and find out what's actually
even legal in this area I have no
connections at all there's a lot of
tourists here I'm asking people if they
rent with they own and they're saying no
ever I actually live in a hotel
which is great because it means there's
a lot of tourists here the hotel
business is fantastic I don't know if
serviced accommodation would work here
maybe
oh man so the hotel business is
absolutely booming everywhere full but
then of course you would expect that
because this is Times Square right in
the very center of New York right now I
feel like a very very small fish in a
very very big pond
okay so literally it's just been going
in and out of hotels and shops asking
people can you tell us anything about
property do you own property do you rent
property and I've just met a guy who is
a property investor in Manhattan in New
York and he owned shops and stuff like
that he's been really really helpful hey
I'm good but I Samuel Samuel am Nabil
great to meet ya the property in New
York City will never lose money we
always buy a property and sell it always
make money so you bought a boy houses
and sell them in New York yes would you
recommend any other areas around like
the outskirts I can say Bronx
rent-to-own do you know anything about
that and do on yeah you can rent it on
obviously you can fix it and then resell
it he says that Lease Option agreements
can work in New York so can you rent a
property in the United States rent it
with an option to buy it later there is
options it always do that you can do
that yes he says that went to rent can
walk but serviced accommodation there
are certain rules and regulations do you
know anything about like Airbnb and
booking com can you put apartments on
that one B&B not allowed in Manhattan
New York okay you know allowed nay not
allowed so where is it allowed Bronx
Brooklyn
borås like Queens sure sure yes Jersey
yeah New Jersey also also you can deal
package and you can sell properties it
works come across anybody like
wholesaling where you package properties
and then you pass them on to investors
and you charge a fee or anything like
that
there are some so it does happen yeah
yeah there are some okay how much rent
do you get for a one-bedroom apartment
in the center of New York three thousand
you know ok three thousand and up
there's no cheap house no no no there's
no cheap houses in this area Midtown
area yeah downtown yes you can go down
what about if we drove lot
three or four hours or definitely yes
where would you have any good areas
three to four hours absolutely two hours
he's introducing me to some heavies
brokers which means the state agents
they call the stages brokers here you
listen to an email yes my contact
details yes and then you'll speak to
some estate brokers state agents and
brokers yes and maybe hook up a meeting
yes definitely I love that yo you're
amazing bro thank you so much so to be
honest I'm thinking that rules wise
there's a I've got a lot of freedom
which is fantastic so now if we rely I'm
getting distracted by talking to people
but I need to sit down and start booking
in some appointments now he's introduced
me to some brokers and some lawyers I
want to meet them they're saying oh we
can meet maybe next week or the week
after I'm thinking I've only got seven
days I need to meet today or tomorrow
but the problem is this is the
equivalent to London center of London in
England and as an investor I don't
behind London because the prices are too
expensive I look outside where people
are bit more motivated so I think what
really we need to do is now 10 past 9:00
I think I need to find somewhere quiet
and just stop hitting the phones and
booking viewings I just need to find
somewhere now with free Wi-Fi
what's a quiet spot where we can just
sit down and make some calls I think we
found that perfect spot
it's got plug sockets Wi-Fi when you
walk in with confidence knowing says
anything so out of these four things
that we need to do today the first one
is book property networking events and I
think that is gonna be a doddle because
look at this literally people say how do
you find proper to networking events how
do you meet the people if I just type in
I just type in property
networking events in New York
we get like absolutely loads if you can
just go on this page on Eventbrite and
this will do this as actually shocked me
today
there's eight events there's this one
this one in Mangal Island
these are all property networking about
elected to a Tuesday the 19th of March
in New York and left over tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow in New York there's 14
events there's this one this is on the
20th of March there's this one there's
this one these are all property real
estate networking events with investors
in New York so I think what I'm going to
do is I think I'm gonna be networking
with a property events in New York every
single night for the whole seven days
this is this is good news this is good
news no longer do I have to go and stop
people in the street and ask if I could
talk to my property it's armed here so
I'm gonna book these right now and I can
tick off another one of the four things
and it's only
20 past 10:00 on the first day so good
stuff good news is we've had an
introduction to a real estate broker
called Rachel and that came from the guy
who gave me a SIM card this morning so
let's call and see if Rachel can help I
have no idea what I'm saying I'm
anything prepared
I don't know this lady from Adam hi
Rachel I've just been given your contact
details by a mutual friend called Nabil
he sold me a SIM card really well I'm
really well thanks so much for taking
the call so so basically yeah I'm
actually I'm from the UK I'm a property
investor and I'm just looking to
potentially get some properties in the
New York area I don't know the area at
all but I wonder if potentially we can
maybe grab a coffee and you could give
me some idea about the kind of
investment so that you broker I have on
right now I'm in Times Square
okay let me just check my diary hold on
Thursday morning what what are you
thinking on Thursday morning yeah yeah
yeah I'm free on Thursday morning where
would you like to meet shall I command
your offices I've got Google Maps so I
can I can find it for sure okay yeah
exactly
you've got it and would you say 10
o'clock would that be good then yeah
that sounds great and yeah I mean bought
by Thursday as well we might have a
little bit more local knowledge and a
bit more of an idea about what we're
wanting to to buy but that sounds great
my friend will be with me he'll be
filming and stuff I hope that I hope
that's okay if I just give you a heads
up I'll send you an email as well Rachel
just kind of confirming the address and
it'll meet you there at 10:00 and anyway
you'll have my key I left my number my
cell phone number and also my email and
I really look forward to meeting you and
thank you ever so much for your time
[Music]
first meeting with a broker fantastic so
there's absolutely loads and loads of
leads online like we can just we can
just Google properties for sale in New
York and there's so many websites
there's like Craigslist
there's always ones I've not even heard
of like this one point two homes realtor
and on here I mean some of these are
really cheap like this one Boonville New
York now this is quite far away from
where we are at the moment but they you
know they are hot really cheap they're
like twenty nine thousand dollars which
is about twenty thousand dollars so you
could literally bar one of those
outright for not that much money however
I just I don't know the market at all I
don't know I mean you can find out how
far away it is from here but I just
doing a let's have a little looks this
was 29 grams so we are
currently I get four hours away okay so
it's quite far to be fair but we don't
have to stay we don't have to stay in
this part of New York we don't have to
with free to go anywhere we want that's
why we have cars
it's what cars are for I'm not stuck in
this area now all these properties that
are for sale there must look there's
like pages and pages and you can click
on them and you can see the person's
phone number look show number boom
that's their number that that's their
number what I do is I buy properties in
the UK from from from usually motivated
sellers people that I've got property it
might be a negative equity or or
whatever and I'll buy the property off
them but I'll take it on and I rent to
buy but then I'll put a tenant in there
is that something is up
is that possible to do Philadelphia okay
well I mean are you but when will be a
good time one will be a good time to to
perhaps meet your pal for now buy the
new today I thought I thought but but I
could I could come down maybe tomorrow
item afternoon come on baby
looks like a little bit later by any
chance maybe I was thinking around about
maybe like three three o'clock we'll
meet wherever you wherever you like
I mean if you've got an office or
anywhere we could meet
okay so looks like we're going to be
going to Philadelphia tomorrow which is
a few hours away in Philadelphia there's
the houses are cheaper there's a lot of
very motivated sellers I've just spoke
to a lady who actually specializes in
rent to own which is quite a lot lease
option agreements so interesting for me
is now we've got all these viewings and
agents through a meeting in New York and
then I've got a meeting in Philadelphia
so we're going to be literally all all
over the states trying to find that
patch but once you found your patch and
you've got a patch that works you can
then dominate that patch so I think I
might stop booking some viewings now for
tomorrow and the next day in
Philadelphia with some really motivated
sellers and then we can meet alia get
the legal side then get the motivated
sellers and then boom get a house
we've no money by the way tonight
we're going to be going to a network
meeting and the plan is I'm going to be
asking Bengals direct yeah I mean
vendors direct no agents because we
caught me so I'm going to be asking
people investors there what properties
they have that are a bit rubbish that
they don't want any more than they're
trying to sell we're going to try and
get their direct all the conversations
that we have I'm going to be secret
filming Inc so we'll be able early in
these videos as well tomorrow or in this
dojo so peace out
thanks so much dude what do you think
about that was interesting basically how
many people were in the audience just me
at one point he went to the toilet
[Music]
you